there are any words that can be used to
describe wyatt earp fearless gunfighter
uncompromising lawman deliver a frontier
justice there can also be a few more
words like murderer or conman or pimp as
you were about to see what Earp was a
complex character full of features and
foibles an icon of the Old West
undoubtedly but calling him a hero might
be stretching it just a bit he's at his
good moments but his life was also full
of questionable actions his persona as a
paragon of justice in those wild
ruthless frontier days was carefully
crafted after his death first by a
biography and then by TV shows movies
and more books today we will take a look
at all the big events in his life a
30-second shootout that defines the Wild
West a quest for revenge taken straight
out of the pages of an adventure novel a
boxing match that might have shown us
that everyone could be bought for the
right price good or bad
these actions helps Mol's one of the
most captivating and legendary figures
in American history
[Music]
he was born white Barry step upon March
the 19th 1848 in Monmouth Illinois to
Nikolas Porter opens Virginia and
Cooksey Wyatt had eight siblings
including one half-brother from his
father's first marriage but for the sake
of brevity we will only single out two
brothers for now Virgil and Morgan Earp
who became gun-slinging lawman like
Wyatt and were right beside him during
his infamous gunfight at the OK Corral
the family moved around during White's
childhood first to pala irons then to
San Bernardino California when the Civil
War broke out its three older brothers
joined the Union Army
according to legend what I'd also wanted
to join the fight despised being only 13
years old at the time he attempted to
run away and illness several times but
his father always managed to track him
down and bring him home as a teenager
Wyatt worked various odd jobs mainly
helping his brothers in driving
stagecoaches and transporting cargo he
also started gambling around this time
lifelong passion of his and he got his
first experience with refereeing boxing
matches something that will have a huge
impact on his life much later in his
early 20s water became a Norman for the
first time after a few years of
traveling and working throughout the
West he settled down and rejoined his
family who by then had relocated again
to Lamar Missouri Nikolas Earp was the
local constable there but in 1869 he
resigned his position and Wyatt was
appointed as his replacement
at that time I fell in love and married
20 year old her Ella Sutherlands but
their relationship was short-lived
she died in 1870 either due to typhoid
fever or childbirth complications as you
might imagine this loss affected White
Hart first he started neglecting his
duties as constable presumably at one
point or another he was either fired or
he quit his job and spent the next few
years drifting from one city to another
going from saloon to bar to brothel I've
got into a few troubles with the law he
was accused of horse theft in Arkansas
and was arrested but escaped jail and
fled Peoria Illinois here he reunited
with his brother Morgan and was often
reported to be in the company of a young
prostitute named Sally Hackl who at
times called herself the wife of white
half
might the charges levied against the
herb brothers by Peoria Norman local
authorities considered the two to be
pimps who ran their own brothel it is
possible that the brothers also took up
buffalo hunting although this is poorly
attested in fact the only solid evidence
is an entry in the diary of their young
sister Adelia earth she wrote that white
and Morgan visited the family farm on
her 11th birthday and brought her a lot
of pretty clothes because they had made
quite a heap of money by hunting Buffalo
of course it is possible that this was
Eliza that the brothers could hide their
less-than-honorable true source of
income
oops Norman career picked up again in
1874 when he was hired as an assistant
marshal in Wichita Kansas the most
memorable events from this period was a
particularly embarrassing one for a man
who had built his reputation as a
gunfighter
the young Wyatt Earp discharged his
revolver by accident when he dropped it
on the floor of a gambling house the
bullet passed through his coat and
caused a quick evacuation of the saloon
allegedly confessed the incident to his
biographer Stuart Lake but asked that he
keep it out of the book in 1876 up left
with guitar and joined the police force
in Dodge City Kansas famed frontier town
during the Wild West he stayed there for
a few years except for a brief spell
where he has generally believed to have
traveled to Deadwood South Dakota with
his brother Morgan well I've got into
his fair share of scrapes as a policeman
in Dodge City and handled many of them
alongside another noted gunslinger of
the era Bat Masterson who we might see
on this channel someday if you guys want
it let us know in the comments below
in 1877 Wyatt er left in pursuit of
outlaw Dave rudabaugh after the former
robbed railroad construction camp he
never caught up to the criminal but the
chase was noteworthy for a different
reason
up met and befriended fellow gambler and
gunslinger Doc Holliday on another
occasion
Wyatt Earp Bat Masterson and several
other people got into a gunfight with a
drunken Posse that was shooting up the
town one of the gunmen named George high
or Hoyt was injured in the shootout and
later died with many historians giving
herbs the credit and touting George high
as the first man that Wyatt Earp killed
however there was never any
our evidence showing who actually hit
him another close call happens around
September 1878 when Edie Morrison and a
rowdy posse of 25 other men were causing
a ruckus at the Long Branch saloon up
when to confront them and was aiming his
beyond of Morris and when one of his
many compatriots reached for his own
weapon fortunately he never got off a
shot because he was hit in the shoulder
by none other than Doc Holliday who had
since relocated Dodge City and was
gambling at the Long Branch saloon when
he stepped in to save his friend now
this is a very nice story but it
probably never happens although did say
that Holliday once saved his life in
Dodge City there are no police records
or newspaper stories of this event even
though the city's history is otherwise
well documented now this seems like a
good place to mention that many of these
lesser-known anecdotes from Wyatt Earp's
life come to us from a single source the
biography of the aforementioned Stuart
Lake titled Wyatt Earp frontier marshal
published in 1931 the book was
absolutely instrumental in creating the
Wild West persona of Wyatt Earp that we
know today
however calling it a biography is rather
deceitful since it had about as much
fiction in it as it did fact a perfect
example of this is the Colt Buntline
special this is one of the most famous
guns of the Wild West because it was the
gun of Wyatt Earp and it had a
distinctive 12 inch barrel however the
only problem is that the gun did not
exist not in Wyatt's time at least Lake
describes the weapon in detail and told
a good story of how it was custom
ordered by dime novelist Ned Buntline
who gave away five of them to famed Old
West lawman it was popular enough to
create a long lasting myth that still
raises doubts today Colt did eventually
start producing this gun during the
1950's because of its popularity and
connection to Wyatt Earp and today it is
a prized artifact for gun collectors
[Music]
so we got a little bit off-track but it
is important to remember how easy it was
to fabricate details about
larger-than-life figures whose exploits
were told mainly through newspaper
stories and pulp novels but let's get
back to the good stuff because what
happened his brothers they located to
the boom town of Tombstone Arizona he
did so in December of 1879 accompanied
by Mattie Blaylock a former prostitute
he became his common-law wife tombstone
had only been founded earlier that year
once prospectors discovered silver in
the area in just several months the
community had grown from a hundred or so
people living in shacks and tents to a
proper town with over a thousand
residents older brother Virgil Earp was
the town marshal while Wyatt and Morgan
worked as private security by riding
shotgun quite literally on Wells Fargo
stagecoaches siblings James and Warren
up also moved to tombstone but for the
most part stayed out of their gun
slinging shenanigans rounding up their
little posse was Doc Holliday who came
along a little later it didn't take long
for the herbs to confront the Cowboys a
group of Outlaws he was quickly grown to
despise them rather than being a
traditional gang the Cowboys were more
of a primitive crime syndicate active in
the Arizona Territory they numbered
hundreds of members that were only
loosely affiliated with one another for
now we will only mention a few of them
who played prominent roles in story they
were the clans and brothers Ike billion
Phineas Frank Stilwell Pete Spence curly
bill Brocius Franken Tom McLaury Billy
Claiborne and spur Johnny Ringo tensions
kept rising as the two groups had
run-ins with each other things took a
serious turn in September of 1881 when
two of the Cowboys Stilwell and Spence
robbed a stagecoach on the standee Bob
lined Bisbee Arizona they were arrested
by a posse which included the two herbs
but were released Virgil Earp arrested
them again a few weeks later this time
on a federal charge of interfering with
a mail shipments they were again let go
because of insufficient evidence but
this act angered the local Cowboys
particularly the McLaurys they claims
that they would kill the herbs if they
ever tried to arrest them again
after weeks of threats the escalating
situation came to a head on October the
26th 1881 that morning an incidence
between water up and Tom McLaury led to
the former pistol whipping the latter
for allegedly carrying a concealed
weapon throughout the rest of the day
McLaury gathered more of his partners
and the Cowboys were seen loitering
angrily around town according to a
recently passed ordinance people had to
surrender any deadly weapons upon
entering tombstone marshal Virgil Earp
intended to disarm the Cowboys and asked
Wyatt Morgan and Doc Holliday to a
system five of them had gathered on
Fremont Street and a vacant lot near the
OK Corral
they were prank and Tom McLaury Billy
and Ike Clanton and Billy Claiborne at
around 3 p.m. the irbs confronted the
Cowboys according to his late testimony
Virgil demanded that they surrendered
their weapons but two of them cocked
their revolvers and then the shooting
started it is impossible to say with any
certainty what the exact sequence of
events was the gunfight at the oka
corral lasted no more than 30 seconds
time during which around 30 shots were
fired
filling the lot with black gunpowder
smoke at the ends Billy Clanton Frank
and Tom McLaury were dead
Ike Clanton and Billy Claiborne were
likely unarmed and they managed to run
away right before the shooting started
Virgil and Morgan Earp and Doc Holliday
had been shot but their injuries weren't
serious Wyatt up alone stood unscathed
[Music]
just 30 seconds created the most famous
gunfight in the history of the Wild West
although newspapers had a heavy
influence on how it was remembered for
starters despite its name it never
actually took place at the okay Corral
but rather right next to it also the
whole thing was more Virgil's affair
rather than wired spit for some reason
the media preferred to focus on the
younger brother maybe it was because he
was the one left standing or maybe this
little extra attention on water was only
applied retroactively Lee as he
continued to have more headline-making
adventures while Virgil for the most
part let a rather unassuming life from
then on either way one part that usually
gets left out of the story is the legal
aftermath that came following the
shootout a few days later Ike Clanton
filed murder charges against the Earp's
and Doc Holliday as Morgan and Virgil
was still recuperating from their wounds
only Wyatt and Holliday were arrested
and brought to court before Judge well
Spicer there were plenty of testimonies
but unsurprisingly they were often
contradictory and were dependent on who
the witnesses sympathized with a lot of
the focus was on who shot first but most
sources agreed that the first two shots
which ostensibly belonged to Billy
kanzen and white earth happened almost
simultaneously what historian who
carefully compared all the natural
testimony's concluded that by and large
they supported the accounts put forward
by the herbs that they tried to disarm
the Cowboys and the gunfight erupted at
the provocation of Clanton and Frank
McLaury judge Spicer agreed and cleared
the herbs and Holliday of any wrongdoing
[Music]
the absurd run the fight but they knew
that there were other Cowboys out there
who'd be looking for revenge as a
precaution the brothers moved their
families to the Cosmopolitan Hotel so
that they could be safer together at
around midnight on December the 28th
1881 Virgil Earp was returning home to
the hotel when he was ambushed by
several men carrying shotguns they
unloaded three or four shots of buck
load into him hitting Virgil in the left
arm head and groin he stumbled into the
hotel and against all odds the doctor
managed to save his life although Virgil
permanently lost the use of his left arm
his shooters they were never identified
although strong suspects included the
remaining clans and brothers Pete Spence
and Johnny Ringo the reprisals they were
not over almost three months later
Morgan Earp was ambushed in a similar
way on March the 18th 1882 he was inside
a billiards parlor playing pool
alongside Wyatt and a few of their
cohorts shots came in through the window
from one or more unidentified assailants
one of the bullets it hit Morgan in the
spine and pissed his left kidney another
one hit the wall inches from Watts head
a doctor was brought in but it was clear
that the injuries were fatal according
to Stewart lay quietens Morgan often
talked about people having visions of
heaven on their deathbed and Morgan's
last words that were whispered in his
brother's ear where I can't see a damn
thing
[Music]
in between the two attacks Wyatt Earp
had been made a deputy US Marshal to
replace his brother Virgil who was no
longer able to fulfill his duties after
the first ambush still held out hope
that the system would deliver justice to
the men responsible however there was a
dearth of evidence not to mention the
fact that any suspect had ten other
Cowboys ready to provide alibis for them
after Morgan was killed watter realized
that he wouldn't have justice but he
could still have vengeance he embarked
on a crusade where he gathered a posse
of many trusted and who knew how to
handle a gun and set off to take out the
Cowboys it became known in Western law
as ups vendetta ride it did not take
long for perps posse do you claim their
first victim the day after Morgan's
death his body was put on a train and
sent to Colton California where his
widow and parents were also on the train
were Virgil and his wife he were leaving
tombstone as he simply became too
dangerous for them White had received
information that some of the Cowboys
were in Tucson where the train would
make a long stop he believes they were
waiting to finish off Virgil so he and
his men accompanied them indeed the
Cowboys were there but they made no
attempt on Virgil's life as he was
surrounded at all times by five men who
were armed to the teeth when his train
departed people had multiple gunshots
coming from the train yard and saw men
running away from the scene left behind
they discovered the riddled body of
Frank Stilwell a cowboy and chief
suspect in Morgan's murder according to
Wyatt Earp's version of events given
decades after the fact he saw Stilwell
and Ike Clanton waiting in ambush on a
flat car in the train yard he and his
men went after them and the Cowboys ran
away but Stilwell stumbled and got left
behind caught up to him and discharged
both shotgun barrels into Stilwell when
he tried to grab his weapon shockingly
even back in the Wild West people
weren't okay with
extrajudicial killing five men were
indicted for Stilwell's murder and
arrest warrants were issued for Wyatt
and Warren earth as well as Doc Holliday
Sherman McMaster and Jack Turkey Creek
Johnson these five can be considered the
original members of the vendetta ride
alongside Texas Jack Vermillion who
didn't travel to Tucson and stayed
behind with the horses Dan Tipton and
Charlie Smith joined them later although
they were now wanted men the vendetta
ride continued into the Dragoon Mound
caught up and killed a cowboy named
Florentino Cruz who according to Wired
served as a lookout the night of
Morgan's murder
unbeknownst to other men suspected of
being involved Pete Spence and an Indian
known as Hank had already been arrested
on other charges Spence even turned
himself in because he realized that he
was safer in jail the vendetta ride
ended with a bang in iron springs in the
wetstone mountains on March the 24th
1882 they had caught up to a Cowboys
posse that had made camp there a
shootout ensued and
recognized curly bill Brocius as being
among the gunmen according to Wyatt he
almost caught Brock eosin - with a
double-barrel shotgun blast to the
stomach another cowboy named Johnny
Barnes is also killed in the gunfight
although miraculously none of UPS men
were even injured now there were still a
few Cowboys who might have been involved
in the attacks on the herbs but well
they met their own violent and
predictable ends that same year Billy
Claiborne was killed in Tombstone by
buckskin Frank Leslie Johnny Ringo was
found dead of an apparent suicide
although for obvious reasons people also
suspected murder
Phineas and Cleansing moved away and a
few years later were charged with cattle
rustling Phineas was taken in and Ike
was killed resisting arrest
there were surprisingly few consequences
for Erb and his Vendetta right some of
the men were arrested but released on
bail and then they left the Arizona
Territory further attempts to extradite
them were unsuccessful
Wyatt Earp moved to San Francisco with
his new partner Josephine Marcus and he
left the Wild West behind in 1883 up
made a brief return to his old ways that
is worthy of inclusion when his friends
and fellow gunfighter Luke short asked
him for his help in a conflict known as
the Dodge City war it ended up being
bloodless and mostly uneventful but it
is memorable for giving us one of the
most iconic photographs of the Wild West
with short and has assembled Posse known
as the Dodge City peace commission it
included some of the wild West's most
famed gunslingers such a short himself
Wyatt Earp of course Bat Masterson and
Charlie Bassett
in his post tombstone life herb tried
his hands in many ventures such as
mining oil horse racing and saloon
ownership even served as a Hollywood
consultant when he lived in Los Angeles
but none of these had memorable moments
that need any mentioning the one job
that did get the people talking big time
though was his stint as a boxing referee
in 1896 the boxing world was left
without a clear undisputed champion
after the previous title holder James J
Corbett retired eventually one match
scheduled for December the second of the
mechanics Pavilion in San Francisco
would settle matter the fighters were
Tom Sharkey and Robert Fitzsimmons but
organizers were having trouble finding a
referee that both sides accepted in the
end they offered the gig to what
appeared the experience and reputation
the fight ended with a controversial
finish when if it Simmons hit Sharkey
with a punch in the 8th rounds Sharkey
fell to the floor clutching his groin in
agony up disqualified Fitzsimmons for a
low blow and gave the victory and the
$10,000 pass that came with it
- Sharkey the Paulin was that always
everyone else saw the punch is a
legitimate hit to the solar plexus that
was immediate talk of the match being
fixed with a pin on the scam an
injunction was placed on the money and
the fight moved to the courtroom
even though up was acquitted of any
fixing charges he remained guilty in the
eyes of the public in his lifetime this
event severely denigrated the reputation
of Wyatt Earp and accusations followed
him until he died in 1929 of liver
disease at the age of 80
it wasn't until Lake published his
biography that Wyatt Earp regains a
positive image although it was a
fanciful and glowing accounts that was
only tangentially connected to reality
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe we got brand new
videos just like this four days a week
Monday through Thursday when you're
subscribing hit the notification bar so
you actually find out when we put out a
new video also why not check out another
channel I do it's called highlight
history it's sort of a today and history
thing I'm gonna link to that below and
as always thank you for watching